nun aber zu ja eher traurigen news aus
brandenburg die tesla produktion startet
im neuen heiß ersehnten riesenberg nun
doch nicht wie versprochen im juli
sondern wahrscheinlich erst nächstes
jahr
ich bin übrigens mal sehr gespannt ob
elon musk der boss auch privat nach
potsdam zieht wenn ich ganz lustig weil
dann ist günther jauch endlich nicht
mehr der reichste potsdamer wo ich mir
auch erst mal verdaut warum die
verzögerung in brandenburg weil komplett
neu geplant werden muss
elon musk will jetzt auf dem gelände
auch noch die größte batteriefabrik der
welt bauen
wow wenn er hat halt diesen herrlichen
hang zum größenwahn tesla chef elon musk
der hat sich nun selber zum könig
gekrönt
ab sofort will der unternehmer nicht
mehr geschäftsführer oder ceo von tesla
genannt werden sondern techno king auf
tesla natürlich finde ich gut meine
mitarbeiter dürfen mich nur noch groß
wie sie auf gegner aber warum baut der
techno king in grünheide dem neuen spree
lecon valley
ich kann sie sagen weil man ihn da
willkommen heißt wenn man theres stolz
ist dass sich der zweitreichste mann der
welt ausgerechnet auf einem
brandenburgischen kurtenacker
niederlässt
diese region bietet so viel das ist sie
sehen wunderbare natur sie sehen grüne
wälder felder und sie sehen den berliner
fernsehturm in der ferne
und das alles zusammen ist eine mixtur
die kann in dieser art und weise
geworden bieten ja so einmalig einmalig
hat sonst keiner steht auch auf dem
neuen werbe plakat von denen brandenburg
von hier aus sieht man den fernsehturm
von einer richtigen stadt elon musk hat
übrigens immer noch keine richtige
baugenehmigung lediglich eine vorab
erlaubnis oder zwölf vorab erlaubnisse
trotzdem durfte er schon einen großteil
der fabrik fertig bauen
ich finde es fast ein bisschen schade
muss ich sagen ich fand es eigentlich
lustig wenn der eon hier mal eine
authentische bürokratie erfahrung
gemacht hätte
also versuchen zu verstehen was die
legendäre brandenburger bauvorlagen
verordnung von einem will dann gibt er
bei google übersetzer grundstücks
entwässerungsplan ein aber weil es das
wort nur im deutschen gibt explodiert
leider sein laptop und ich finde man
sollte auch mehr erleben wie das
wirklich ist wenn man einen deutschen
handwerker fragt ob er nächsten monat
anfangen kann ja hätte ich ihm so
gewünscht die erfahrung
stattdessen haben sie ihn mitten im
trinkwasserschutzgebiet von der
trinkwasserschutz verordnung befreit
nachdem brandenburger motto was muss
gehört muss man schätzt tesla produktion
und batteriefabrik verbrauchen später
zusammen fast 400.000 liter wasser pro
stunde wie eine mittelgroße stadt
einerseits immer der fall jetzt wegen
simon maske stirbt oder am borkenkäfer
aber ich denke dass wir im grunde nicht
in einer sehr trockenen region sind in
den letzten drei jahren haben wir unter
der dürre gelitten java ich meine diese
bäume hier würden ja nicht wachsen wenn
es kein wasser gäbe
ich meine wir sind hier nicht in der
wüste ja eben neben und selbst wenn das
eine wüste wird wegen seiner fabrik kann
man ja immer noch den berliner
fernsehturm sehen ohne wald sogar besser
ich meine klar herr maas schafft
arbeitsplätze nicht wenige
und er hat natürlich auch eine geniale
seite ich sag nur raumfahrt und mal ganz
ehrlich wo stünde denn das ganze thema e
auto ohne elon musk für seine visionen
wird davon fans regelrecht kultisch
verehrt auf der ganzen welt vor allem
aber natürlich an der börse im
paralleluniversum börse ist tesla mehr
wert als alle deutschen autobauer
zusammen gerechnet
bei gerade mal 500.000 produzierten
autos im jahr
tatsächlich sind aktuell ist kein witz
in deutschland immer noch mehr trabis
zugelassen als teslas ist fakt und ich
wette
sobald erinnern dass mitkriegt haut
direkt den nächsten mega trend raus
viele mmos präsentiert die zukunft aus
dem hause tesla brandenburg ein
revolutionäres neues antriebskonzept
ganz ohne altmodischen elektromotor ein
hochmoderner zweitaktmotor mit
ökologischen 23 ps
wir verwandeln pflanzenabfälle in
bewegungsenergie das geheimnis
natürlicher kohlenstoff wie man nur aus
der erde
der tesla band die zukunft der mobilität
die auslieferung von 12 bis 15 jahre
dauern
[Musik]
ja die wartezeit lohnt sich in jedem
fall vorteile sind der geilen sound und
der geruch das fehlt im auto übrigens
wird elon musk genau heute abend vom
land brandenburg zum unternehmer des
jahres ernannt und wir schalten wir live
zur feierstunde in potsdam zu valerie -
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das rundfunk sinfonieorchester des rbb
in der wegen der gebühren diskussionen
runter gesparten version
meine damen und herren elon musk und
seine fabrik sind für das land
brandenburg längst ein must have
die größte autofabrik der welt hier bei
uns im kleinen brandenburg wahnsinn gut
liegt vielleicht auch daran dass man am
anfang dachte er baut in berlin
aber das konnten wir schnell aufklären
totally excited diese fabrik in berlin
zu bauen und ich dann in meiner
charmanten art und weise gesagt hat
nicht ganz stück daneben brandenburg
elon musk twittert an seine 40 millionen
follower
riga berlin also doch berlin
ja macht nichts bevor er sich jetzt das
furchtbare wort brandenburg merken muss
benennen wir einfach unser land um
willkommen in gera berlin
ich bin ein gegner grillen und jetzt
kommt meine damen und herren elon musk
ist uns person live zugeschaltet helau
helau hieß so happy to be missed
astronaut er kannst du nicht so zeigen
die onvista techno king ja majesty you
will make our country or better place
germany wiesmoor elektromobilität in
other words gerade in den städten gibt
es riesige einsatz märkte für
elektrofahrzeuge und ja und wenn die
großen automobilhersteller sich nicht
beeilen und werden kleinere ihnen ganze
stücke kuchen vom brot nehmen altes
deutsches sprichwort what it takes you
say that any way bis mama
es gab da ja zuletzt gerüchte über
polnische arbeiter die für den giga lot
von acht euro 70 auf der baustelle
ackern
falls das stimmt wäre das tatsächlich
ein bisschen illegal entließ remember me
the polish boxer spargelernte
dazu muss man wissen der elan arbeitet
ungern mit gewerkschaften also im sinne
von gar nicht tarifverträge mager nicht
und da kriegen wir möglicherweise ein
winziges problemchen weil du kannst das
nicht wissen aber wir deutschen lieben
unsere gewerkschaft am erstmal
arbeiterklasse trinkt bier bratwurst
änderten sich irgendwie bizarr fanny
traditions fässler ist berüchtigt für
massen von überstunden und deswegen
frage ich ihn jetzt einfach mal direkt
violau gewerkschaften in yoga fabrik wo
du okay kein problem wird sich irgendwie
einrichten und nun spielt das rbb
orchester exklusiv für elon musk alle
sechs brandenburgischen konzerte von
johann sebastian bach gute unterhaltung
[Musik]
schade er hat sich abgemeldet ja hätte
ich ja auch valerie niehaus vielen dank
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen aber da